hello Mrs Jordan thank you so much for
coming hi Mike please come with me
Michael Jordan is such an important
cultural figure and so there was one
person I wanted to do justice to was
Michael and he was generous enough to
sit down with me he mentioned he wanted
Dolores Jordan to be played by Viola
Davis and Matt Damon and I realized that
that was really the protagonist of the
story that the hero of the story would
be Dolores Jordan Ben and I both really
responded to Alex con's script the first
time we read it and just thought it was
such an interesting story you know
having lived through it and experienced
it as kind of a teenager when Michael
Jordan came onto the scene and really
changed the world as we knew it in terms
of the NBA and the culture and I think
will surprise people when they see the
movie like where Nike was versus where
they are today and I just always found
it was one of those scripts that any
time I picked it up I would just sit for
an hour and a half and read the whole
thing
he doesn't want to be here but he will
listen he promised me that you have our
attention I didn't know that Delores
broker the deal and just a lot of the
players that are involved mean of the
characters I loved it I thought it was
smart and it was funny and it was honest
Jordan so good to see you so pleasure Mr
Jordan how are you only other brother in
the room and your lady oh J was my fault
I will tell you what happened well this
my m m what's up Champion good to see
you I was excited about the movie
because it had all the things that I
loved basketball Michael Jordan Jordan
shoes Ben athle and Matt Damon Viola
Davis Jason baitman so many great people
that was in the movie Take a
Look they're called Air
Jordan what do you think about
that the unveiling of the shoe just huge
for the movie I was watching Matt and
Ben work on it in front of the camera
try this try that cutting lines adding
lines and then watching everyone at the
boardroom table take that in the
boardroom scene was certainly the most
challenging scene in the film and I knew
it when I read the script there's 10
people around a table which is always
hard in the attention around the room I
have these great actors like the looks
between Chris Tucker and Matt and Phil
looking at Matt finding all those
moments and weaving them in and that was
such a natural way to impose tension on
the scene so what are your thoughts BL
colors I thought the NBA had a rule on
color yeah they do um they want it all
white and with all due respect to them
they can go to hell we're going to pay
the fines uh for Michael every game
what's interesting to us about this
moment in Nike is that Phil was a pirate
and kind of a revolutionary but suddenly
he finds himself the captain of the ship
and so he's trying to run a billion
dollar company now he's got all these
employees he's got all of these
responsibilities but he's still got this
mindset it was fun playing around with
what a CEO of a scrappy company would
look like and a lot of it's based on
Phil Knights suiting during that time
but also yeah he would come to that
meeting in this blue Glen plaid suit
that's kind of obnoxious it's like I'm
the CEO of this company I think it just
lent really really well to the comedic
timing and and his perform
is excuse me hi hey sorry I'm late Mark
Phil I was just explaining to Michael
that we're going to uh I was I'm just
was explaining for a second that that
that I'm the CEO of this company and
it's worth nearly a billion dollars now
and I'm so extremely busy it's almost
impossible to imagine but this meeting
was so important I told my secretary I
wasn't going to miss this no matter what
that's how important this is go ahead
Sunny well I was just telling Michael
that we were going to pay any finds
incurred by the shoes
design
oh we looked at some reference of the
Nike boardroom and I was going down the
path of kind of recreating that and Ben
was like you know what I really feel
like it should be a darker wood panel
space because I wanted to feel more
mysterious and so I pivoted to this
darker room and I think it really helped
the magic trick that was happening where
you don't see Michael Jordan's face at
all I'm sorry turn it off Rob turn it
off just please
forget about the shoes forget about the
money you're going to make enough money
it's not going to matter it can't buy
you immortality that you have to
earn I'm going to look you in the eyes
and I'm going to tell you the
future you wield your way to the NBA
you're going to win championships it's
an American story and that's why
Americans are going to love it the
reason why I really like using the Flash
Forward in the conference room is I
looked at a shot of you looking at your
son when Matt was talking about the
future and it it looked to me as if his
mother not only believes in him that
he's great but she's really the only one
at the table who also has an empathy for
how that is going to be hard she was a
woman with vision and she understood
exactly who her son was she knew his
potential and she had faith in it a shoe
is just a
shoe until somebody steps into it then
it has
meaning you're Michael Jordan and your
story is going to make us want to
fly thank you Mr vakaro Mr Knight Mr
straser Mr White thank
you Mr thank you Mr thank you Michael
call me
anytime great speech emotional great
thanks
David
Mr
viaro Mr
Jordan I have some news for
you just do it you didn't expect me to
call this is a pleasant surprise I
promise Ben did something really
remarkable that I had never seen before
and he insisted on doing all the
telephone conversations for real in the
movie so all of the scen with telephone
calls were actually done live with like
analog cable connecting the sets so we
built Viola's set the Jordan interior in
a corner of the the office building
where we had our Nike offices and it was
really a minuscule little uh kitchen set
but it was really authentic to North
Carolina Michael will accept the 250,000
salary guaranteed and the shoe will be
named for Michael and family what what
yes uh really the benefit of that phone
call Viola was like you know Matt gets
the news and he's like pumped fist
pumping and she can't see that you know
and see you get the ability as an actor
or as a person on the phone to do like a
lot of behavior that you wouldn't do so
all those things add this whole layer of
texture and a whole layer of tension and
it's because it's on the phone and not
and because they're not next to each
other now we are willing to accept the
deal in commit right away but with one
minor provision name it Michael will get
a percentage of the revenue of the sale
of each shoe that is
sold I'm sorry not all Nike shoes just
the ones with his name on
them oh uh Mrs Jordan so that's not how
the business works at all I mean I I
understand you eat we eat that's all
he's asking that's a fair point but
that's just not how business works there
was a real dignity and comfort that I
loved how you played the scene so evenly
so many times and we shot it the
camera's on you and the camera's on that
and I thought this is a big experiment
because we're with him the whole time
and we think he's right and he's our
protagonist he's supposed to be right
and then he gets on the phone with you
and you patiently explain to him why
he's wrong they invest the capital and
they get the reward and that's how it
goes well maybe that needs a change
because if he does what I think he's
going to do what you also think he's
going to do and what Michael knows he's
going to do then it won't be the NBA
promoting my son I promise you it'll be
the other way around and in that case he
deserves a piece and not only that there
was a moment that you did a first take
you had the phone you're listening to it
and in the part of his speech that I
thought was the most convincing just
took it away from your face and held it
about this far away I saw a whole
lifetime of somebody being lectured to
and told that things that work Fair were
fair and that they didn't deserve that
was how it was and that they had to live
with it I thought like that that's it
that's
Jesus Mr bakaro I agree that the
business is
unfair but every once in a while someone
comes along that's so extraordinary that
it forces those reluctant to part with
some of that wealth to do so not out of
Charity but out of greed because they
are so very special
I do not believe Dolores may think
otherwise that she knew absolutely from
the beginning what she was going to ask
for it's the Journey of believing that
that's what he deserves knowing that
that's his potential and Having the
courage and the guts to ask for it but
above all was the impact that Michael
felt his mother had on him and on the
deal and on this moment in his life and
so that really became the thrust of the
movie for us Michael Jordan is probably
the greatest athlete in modern history
and this story tells us I can accomplish
that thing that I I dared not dream I
could accomplish and I think that's a
really important thing for people to
have a shoe is just a
shoe until my son steps into
it